alors vous avez eu le prix Nobel ouais ils
vous l'ont donné pour quelle raison ils
pourraient expliquer que nous avons une lauréate du prix Nobel de la paix
Nadia Murad qui a été prise par Isis et
mise dans une situation horrible dans laquelle
elle se trouve mais elle a été une
avocate exceptionnelle j'espère que vous  peut appeler ou quoi que ce soit
aux irakiens et kurdes et au gouvernement ce qu'Isis
est Dieu mais si je sais que c'est le
gouvernement kurde et irakien si je ne peux pas aller
chez moi et vivre dans un endroit sûr et obtenir
mon comme ma dignité comme ça ne
concerne pas Isis c'est à propos  un inventeur mon
peuple ne peut pas revenir en arrière
nous ne sommes pas des millions de personnes nous
ne sommes qu'un demi-million de personnes
ne peut pas trouver un endroit sûr pour vivre
tout cela m'est arrivé ils ont gardé ma mère
mon sixième frère ils ont laissé derrière eux
vous savez qu'ils ont tué
Prix ​​Nobel ouais ils vous l'ont donné
pour quelle raison peut expliquer
pour quelle raison après tout ce qui m'est
arrivé je n'ai pas donné je peux je
fais comprendre à tout le monde qu'Isis a
violé des milliers d'années Edie femme celle-
ci était la première  la fois où la femme d'Irak
elle est sortie et a parlé de cela heureux pour la
première fois d'O'Malley je suis sûr que
vous vous êtes échappé mais je n'ai pas
ma liberté qui est Isis nous ne
savons pas s'ils ont tué  tous les jours tout le monde
s'ils sont en prison mais nous savons que nous avons
3 000 ans Edie
femmes et enfants y compris ma nièce mon
neveu ma belle-sœur il y a trois ans
elle nous a appelés elle a dit que j'étais en Syrie et
maintenant nous ne savions pas  quoi que ce soit, laissez-moi
bien paraître merci
[Musique]